good people of the internet welcome to
the podcast my guest today
is my buddy john moffett john is
a two-time olympic swimmer he's a former
world record holder turned three-time
emmy award-winning television producer
he's a storyteller now a podcaster just
an amazing
human being this is an incredible
conversation about
sport life everything in between john is
one of my oldest friends we've known
each other for
35 years at this point this podcast is
long overdue
and i hope you enjoy it if you enjoy the
content that we
create and share on this channel please
hit that subscribe button
hit that notification bell and without
further ado please enjoy my conversation
with john moffatt
[Music]
are we ready to go i'm ready as i will
ever be
so we sat down and did a two-hour
podcast it must have been
2013. i think it was right after you
started if i remember correctly
i think you might have even been in like
the 20s or something like that as far as
the number goes what are you up to now
545 or something like that
so yeah that was over seven years ago
and one of my very few uh complete
mishaps where i believe like it didn't
record at all
or something happened the audio got
corrupted it was unusable
or i just didn't have the audio file and
i remember calling
it didn't work and you can't just repeat
it
you know it's like we just had this
experience and i always thought like in
the back of my mind well we'll do it
let's let some time pass
right and we'll revisit it and then
seven years went by and we never did it
so
well which is kind of the way our lives
have been i mean we've certainly been
living them in parallel
but but you know rich we do disappear
from each other's lives for various
reasons whether it be family or other
circumstances
uh just as a preferatory note john
is one of my oldest oldest friends i've
known you since i was 17 or 18 years old
and you you know we've shared a lot of
life experiences over the years but in
adulthood it's been a it's kind of been
a pick and roll thing like i'll see you
once a year i'll see you and we'll make
plans to see each other and then life
intervenes and you know i take
responsibility i'm terrible
at like maintaining my friendships
and a lot of time has passed and time
lost spent with you but i always enjoy
seeing you
man and i'm glad to have you in my life
well one of the strengths of our
friendships is that we're able to pick
up right where we left off yeah
i mean it is it's uncanny you know how
we won't see each other for
a year or two and somehow we don't miss
a beat and within
a few minutes we're cracking jokes and
you know just picking up where we left
off so
uh you know there's there's room in life
for friends like that
and life is complex and we get busy
and you just have to be able to pick and
choose it's like if it's worth
seeing somebody maybe you can only see
them once a year or once every two years
or maybe you see them a whole bunch of
times in one year then you don't see
them for a few more
yeah and that's kind of been the pattern
yeah well hopefully we can rectify that
a little bit
but i'm reluctant to make broad promises
that i can't keep because i've done that
in the past
um what's really cool about
having you here today you know in
reflecting i was reflecting on
the history of our relationship and and
trying to wrap my head around
um this podcast today is that you've
played like this sort of
important but kind of shadowy role in my
life like behind the scenes like
yeah it's crazy like i i wrote a little
bit anybody who's read finding ultra you
pop up a couple times in the book so
people might be familiar with who you
are um but
in many ways i'm not sure i would have
ever even moved to los
angeles if it wasn't for you in in
certain
ways like almost you know unbeknownst to
you like
i was a lawyer in san francisco we'll go
back over the history of
relationships but our relationship but
um i was a lawyer in san francisco
i was unhappy in my professional
situation
i really wanted to move down to los
angeles and get involved in
entertainment
and i'd given you my resume right at the
time you were working at
not extra it was hard copy yeah hard
copy yeah
reality tv 1.0 which we're going to get
into
indeed yeah your career and then i just
forgot about it
and then suddenly like i don't know
maybe four or six weeks later
i get a call from a law firm in los
angeles saying they wanted to interview
me but it was a law firm that i'd never
sent my resume to
and i was like how do they even know but
it was a really good firm
and i called in sick at my law firm and
booked a southwest flight down from san
francisco to la
to do this interview i board the plane
and you're on my flight
and we're sitting next to each other
these are assigned seats back then
did we did we do the math at that point
and realize that you had given my resume
to adam bram
and that's how it ended up at
christensen or i think that was later
not that not that i recall
i do remember actually giving my resume
your resume to adam yeah because he was
kind of general
counsel for hard copy he was and he was
uh an incredibly dynamic
incr amazingly talented and
intelligent person just would pick up on
things
so quickly in the subtlety of things
were not lost on him and he
so i thought that you know he would be a
good person to pass your resume to and i
remember him being
impressed immediately but i didn't know
that subsequently he had passed it on
right yeah that our lives would meet up
once again because of that little thing
and then i end up getting that job i
moved to los angeles i work at that law
firm
uh and then subsequent to that i end up
leaving that law firm and going to work
for
a client that client
ended up hiring adam bram as his sort of
personal michael cohen type situation
and i
ended up working with adam who was the
original
reason that i got that first job in the
first place which all tracks back to you
uh adam has since passed away
unfortunately
um he was a good friend to both of us
and there's a whole story there but
um yeah man i've now been living in la
for many years but it all started with
you slipping my resume to adam brown
that was probably what circa 1995
94 94 yeah no
96 sorry 96. i graduated from law school
in 94. okay
but let's take it back man um well first
of all
uh to speak to the seven year window in
between
you know when we first did a podcast and
and doing it now
i've learned to trust that these things
happen when they're supposed to
that there's a reason for them and
what's great about us doing this today
is that you're launching your own
podcast right so
we could talk a little bit about that
and hopefully i can blow a little wind
in your sails to get people
interested in what you're about to
launch so maybe talk about that for a
second
oh yeah that would be that would be
great well first of all i have always
been
immensely impressed with your podcast
and the
the scope and breadth of the topics that
you are
able to tackle um and just your overall
ability just to be personable
and to elicit really authentic responses
and um my life uh
i was working on a project that you
actually were involved in long time ago
which was a boycott about the 19
or a film about the boycott of 1980
olympic games um and by the united
states um and
i was working with uh lebron james's
people
um and we said at the outset this is at
the end of
uh must have been the end of 2018 when
we embarked on the partnership
that if we can't make get it made with
lebron james
we we can't get it made it's not going
to get made because you know
you and i tried to get it made right i
thought it was looking good and
and it subsequently sort of disappeared
from the radar and that happened many
times through the years and it was
somewhere around 10 12 years later that
i
was able to finally partner with uh
lebron's companies
so i started undefeated
yeah and spring hill spring hill was
involved as well
but it was mostly an uninterrupted
project unbelievably
intelligent people over there they're
just
they're just masters they were really
really great to work with
but the bottom line is is that the the
after
thinking that we were going to get it
made last summer
um for a release this summer um
everything blew up once again and we had
a few opportunities for hail mary's
right you know toward the end and that
last kind of hail mary
was at the beginning of this year uh
really before covet hit
and so i was basically faced
with a situation because it it
they passed the last it was like our
last last hail mary
they passed and i was faced with
uh what am i going to do now yeah
because i didn't have a stomach for
really continuing on with one foot in
the entertainment business and one foot
this documentary has been your passion
project forever i mean that's
it's my heart goes out to you man not
being able to set it up it's such a
great story too
well yeah i mean it's the bottom line is
that people don't want to hear it and
that's that's the key toward doing uh
anything that can be sold and that
people that people have to want to hear
it so for whatever reason there's
something in that story that
made people not want to want to tell the
story with me
do you think it's because it just
happened so long ago it's ancient
history it's not relevant to what's
happening today i mean there's so many
themes and threats to pull in that story
that are
completely pertinent to the geopolitical
sports landscape that we're mired in at
the moment
well i think yeah that that is certainly
the case
um and and with the with the
postponement of the 2020 games in tokyo
i think that
you know suddenly okay we have another
us olympic team
that has to put their dreams on hold not
for four years like we had to do in 1982
you know and our next
chance was 1984 but for at least a year
uh provided that the 2021 games go on
and as you know as an athlete and as you
know as the
razor thin like margin for error that
you have to have in order to perform at
that level
a year is a long time super long yeah
super long
i mean it will play into the favor of
the younger athletes that still could
benefit from
another year of training but a lot of
the training resources are unavailable
at the moment and for people that are in
the twilight of their career it's
devastating
yeah can you really hang on for another
year and
you know on top of that there's this you
know misguided idea
that these athletes are well-funded
enough to support themselves and train
and
they're not that's just not the case
with the exception of a very few it
really never has been
i mean with with the exception of a
select few
yeah yeah yeah it's rough so also yeah
so i felt
i felt as though okay you get these
times in your life where you're like
okay i need to reinvent myself
i need to figure out what i'm gonna do
and i love storytelling and i love
i love athletes i love their
struggles and the whole endeavor of
of striving to do something bigger than
yourself
for who knows just to be human right to
celebrate being human
and so i was trying to figure out okay
what am i going to do to
that i can you leverage my
experience as a storyteller but
something that i can do
myself and not carry with me the burden
of huge financial
implications of actual production where
you have cameras and
you know lots and lots of employees etc
so i thought well let's
let's make crack at doing a podcast
so that's what i'm in the process of
doing
i love it man uh when you told me this
on the phone the other day i i
i couldn't be more enthusiastic i think
uh
you know there's a we're in this you
know golden
moment where podcasting has now you know
become
a really mainstream media outlet there's
lots of people starting podcasts so it's
much more competitive than it used to be
but nobody is better suited
to shepherd these athlete stories than
yourself not only because
you are an athlete yourself and you have
this extraordinary olympic pedigree that
we're going to unpack but also
you have an entire career in
storytelling and i don't know anybody
else
who is as qualified or well
suited to embark upon this project who
else is an olympic athlete who also
has this amount of experience in
sharing stories and understanding what
makes a story
work and why it's worthwhile well i
appreciate the vote of confidence but as
you know whenever you embark on anything
new there is there's you know doubt yeah
and and we all we look i'm fully aware
that the
the market is pretty much completely
saturated and that
you know you did it right starting your
podcast
that was just 2012. well luck is a big
factor in success for
a lot of things in life um you know some
hope i really appreciate you sitting
down as well
um because you carry with you a great
amount of respect
and insight it and and you wouldn't have
the respect and the popularity if you
didn't
take that insight with you but i will be
the
the least accomplished athlete to ever
be on your podcast probably
well uh i have i've already interviewed
somebody who was a ballerina
and didn't have any any experience in
athletics
beyond that so that's an art form
yeah but but this person is amazing cool
um what do you do you have a name for it
because when we talked on the phone the
other day you weren't sure what you were
going to call it uh
well it's a working title right now so i
wish that i had something
completely concrete
the the title the title that we are
working with right now
is sports life balance so it's a riff on
work-life balance that anybody who knows
with a family and had to also work
especially for
mothers that it's it's tough
and so it's the lessons from sports
that will can be reapplied for life
and that's the whole premise behind it
that these people
who were at one point in their life's
great athletes
they have also been able to parlay
that success somehow into having
successful
thriving happy lives and what what are
those ingredients
what are the secret sauce in the pixie
dust that goes into
somebody leading a happy and balanced
life
yeah yeah it's interesting and it's it's
more complicated than meets the eye
this is something that i explored with
apollo ono on the podcast recently you
would think
that any athlete that ascends to you
know the apex of
performance understands what it takes to
be
successful in the world like they know
how to apply themselves they know how to
set goals and achieve them they know how
to
you know focus and that you know they
know how to um
you know show up in those specific
moments and perform like all of these
things that are life skills
and yet it's the exception
to the rule when you see somebody retire
from their
athletic career and then become equally
or
you know significantly successful in
civilian pursuits why is that you know
it's interesting you would think like
anybody who knows how to do this should
be able to just kill it in the real
world
and it doesn't happen as often as you
would suspect
no i i think it certainly doesn't and
um i know with apollo you were talking
um you were talking about the weight of
gold
yeah which he is featured in um and
the weight of gold is i think an amazing
hour of of television or hbo so
but so it's kind of a short film um
but what it what it does is it kind of
lifts the veil this is this is what when
groups of olympians and paralympians get
together
this is this is a topic of conversation
like how
do you how do you move on from your time
in sport a time when you are
at the pinnacle at a very young age you
have
immense respect from your peers and from
those in positions of authority around
you
and suddenly you retire and you land
in nowheresville yeah and nobody cares
yeah yeah so there isn't
any one particular method that works for
everybody everybody is different
as as you well know um the way i went
about doing it is i i
just decided that i needed to completely
reinvent myself and i turned my back
on the sport of swimming
because i i was i was determined to
prove
that i'm worthy of something other than
just being a really good swimmer i
didn't
i i did not want to just be known as
that swimmer when i was in my teens and
20s
right i wanted to do something else so
you developed
a passion for storytelling in film while
you were still
competing and we're gonna we'll get into
that but you had that
kind of you know working in parallel
behind the scenes so that when you
retired you already kind of knew what
you wanted to do
yeah yeah i i kind of did i had no idea
how i was going to go about it
but what you're referring to is that i
was featured in bud greenspan's yeah
film about the 1984 olympic games
because they didn't go very well for me
i just watched that clip it's on youtube
yeah your little segment
you can watch it it's all grainy and
stuff like that but i watched it this
morning and
it's just it pulls on my heartstrings
still to this day yeah it wasn't a very
good day
but you know the the the you know i
spoke that you know luck has a great
deal to do with
with success and where you ultimate
where your life ultimately
ends up leading um and one of those
things was bud greenspan deciding that
he wanted to
uh use me as one of the feature stories
with rowdy gaines
right kind of like parallel stories of
of the agony of defeat and the
ecstasy of victory yeah yeah for those
that don't know bud greenspan
was a legendary documentarian who was
immersed in the olympic movement and
would make these extraordinary
documentaries
about each olympic games and probably
his finest work was 16 days of glory
which was
his documentary on the 1984 olympic
games in which you
featured in that segment that you just
described
is that fair is that fair to say yeah
stuff i mean the guy was a legend
he he did i mean he was he he made i do
not know
exactly how many official olympic films
but
16 days of glory which chronicled the
1984 summer olympics in los angeles
was certainly uh one that
had quite a bit of fanfare at the time
um and him featuring me that in that
film
it didn't it it wasn't it wasn't
actually being featured in the film that
made a difference in my lives
life but it was him
and i really hitting it off and
him kind of or the way i thought about
it in my mind was that he was my mentor
he was my mentor to you he really did
and we kept in touch through the years
and i certainly would
i kept in touch with all of the updates
of what i was up to
and you know that's what that's what
changed me it's you know it's the fact
that he was willing to take me under his
wing and
and he was supportive when you know
let's face it
people aren't always supportive of you
going into a career in the entertainment
business yeah
my family was indifferent to act
you know completely uh
non-supportive at all you know so
i mean i'm sure you understand yeah you
understand that yeah yeah yeah and
yeah it's it's such a scary thing and so
unpredictable
you know who wants their kid to go into
a thing where the future
you know is the the likelihood of
success is so rare
true and it's it is a tough business
yeah
and you grew up in la but la's a big
place you grew up
not it's not like you grew up in
hollywood around all of this no i grew
up in claremont
[Laughter]
which you know it's a little different
than cultural totally different than
hollywood yeah
um i went to high school in newport
beach which is all together
polar opposites and right ways than
holly right hollywood who is the guy
who does the voice-overs in those movies
the serie that serious tone with this
his brother
is it yeah because we used to we used to
make fun of that guy in college you
remember you
me and kurt would be like wyomiatius
everyone did that
everyone did that because it's like that
was like that was the
that's what wrong in your head like when
you would fall asleep dreaming of
you know you're standing on the blocks
and you picture that voice you know
coming out of ether and like
there's something just so epic about it
it was timeless you know there was there
was and it lended
a seriousness to it like this matters
like this is a big deal
yeah i think much like like john
williams and his music and his music
score especially the one that he
the scores that he made for the 84 games
there's a signature there you know you
know exactly what you're getting
yourself into
when you hear a john williams you know
fanfare
or or you hear the voice from those
films
you're being psychologically teed up for
something big right yeah yeah exactly
all right so i'm a kid uh growing up in
the suburbs of washington dc
starting to fall in love with the sport
of swimming and
the cork board above my bed started to
become
a collage of tear sheets from swimming
world magazine
i'm having dreams of you know my own
career and i had
some level of acumen and skill i
certainly wasn't
the most talented swimmer on my club
team but i learned early
that i could bridge that talent deficit
gap by by working really hard
and so by the time i was 16 i was
starting to kind of
make a few waves in my local area
and there was one image on
on my cork board of you
you were it was a i don't know if you
remember this you couldn't have been
older than like
maybe you were 15 or 16 years old and
you were it was like a
mid-dive like you were you were bursting
off the blocks and you were just like
shredded and ripped and i just thought
like this guy man like he's got it going
on
um i can't remember that must have been
it must have been after
it was probably taken around
80 maybe 83 or something like that in
the lead up to the 84 games
um you are this is a long way of saying
like you were one of my original
inspirations and original heroes in the
sport of swimming
um just to kind of bring people up to
speed
you burst onto the scene relatively
quickly in the sport of swimming
distinguished yourself
and made your first olympic team in 1980
at the age of
16 16. you were 16 years old yeah you
were the youngest kid on the team
right i was the youngest male on the
entire u.s
squad of all sports all sports the
youngest
athlete to make the 1980 team i i have
been i i've been told
um that the person that became the
youngest after me was
michael phelps so that would have been
two thousand
i think he was 15 yeah so wow
yeah so what was that like man
do you even even like were you able to
even process that at that age
of course of course i mean i think even
at 16 years old
it's the same facilities that allow you
to aspire towards something like that
is is also what makes you understand the
gravity and the
in the largeness of scale of what you're
trying to do
um so yeah i certainly was aware
i think it was overshadowed
which is a nice term to because of the
boycott because we had found out that
carter
carter's boycott succeeded um and that
we were in fact boycotting
a few months before the trials it was
april that we actually found out about
that so we knew
we knew and so i i think that
no matter what there was some luster
taken off of it but we also knew that
the united states was still gonna pick
an olympic team yeah
um i will tell you that you are when
you're that age you don't
quite know what you're doing
in other words in other words you don't
have as many
scars and wounds
painful reminders of what it's like to
to really get your butt kicked
when you're really young and of course
of course as we get older we start
experiencing more of that and as we
climb up through the ranks
so by the time 84 rolled around you know
i'd been
i'd been around the block as far as
swimming against the best in the world
and and really getting you know you get
buffeted about
and so you it's a very different thing
in 84 because i just had
more experience under my belt and i
understood
how rare it was to actually make it
there and so many of my friends who
were with me on the 1980 team
didn't make it 84. which was a whole
nother level
yeah craig beardsley and glenn mills and
sue walsh and mary beth linsmeyer
there are there are a number of them
um or or then you take a sippy woodhead
or
or a tracy caulkins who who in essence
missed their prime
you know what i mean so there there was
a fair amount of of heartbreak
um associated with both those games and
in my peers because we did get to know
each other very well because
you know when you you know what it's
like when you're when you're in the
trenches
with a group of people like at let's say
at stanford right and
i really get to know each other level
but yes i know what you're saying the
dynamics are not
all together different um you're still
just swimmers you're still
dealing with pain you're still dealing
with injuries you're still dealing with
doubt
you know there's there's you know the
inevitable politics the coach giving you
a stupid set i mean there's all that
stuff it's still
is is not that different you're just
you've just been lucky enough to have
been selected to take it to that next
level
and in 84 you're only 20. yeah you know
yeah at the time that was like okay
you're at the peak
now it's a whole different ball game
you're you're right yeah
you could have been you could have been
still gutting for it at
you know 32. it was a very different
time back then and
i think what people need to realize is
that for the most part unless you were
independently wealthy and your
family was willing to support you you
you didn't have any support after
college
yeah well it wasn't even part of the
mental calculus like
who is who is continuing to do it like
it's so different now but at the time it
was like yeah you're done
well in case in point myself and and
pablo morales
decided to take a uh you know take a
year to train for 88
and we had both graduated at that point
and it didn't it didn't work out
right um so yeah it's it's fraught with
um
it's fraught with peril and you and like
i said earlier alluded to earlier
the older you get the the more battle
scars
and painful reminders you have of what
it's like to come up short
because shooting high means you land
really hard if you miss
in 80 you still went to the white house
though right yeah
what was that like that is a blur
um i remember distinctly being filed
into
a room and at one point i knew which
room it wasn't within the white house
but
it was a room and we were we were all
lined up
and we were in our little red parade
uniforms
and our hats right and are
um like levi's did the universe levi's
did the uniform yeah
both for 80 and 84 in fact the uniforms
were exactly the same in
84 as they were in 80s they just had a
whole bunch of left over i guess
but um but yeah i remember lining up and
then
in walks the president which is surreal
to be
in the same room as the president of the
united states in this case it was
president jimmy carter
the same uh same man who um
basically used us as pawns uh in order
to protest uh
politically protest the soviet invasion
of afghanistan
at the end of 1979 um and we were used
you know for his political gains so it
was very mixed it was
all of us were upset upset
some people actually said they supported
it but everyone was quite upset
so it's very bittersweet and um i don't
remember the exact sequence of things
but at some point
we got these medals um and
it wasn't carter that gave us the medals
but we had the medals around our neck is
my recollection
when he came in and i i remember like
thinking you know picking up and looking
at it and kind of like thinking to
myself
uh great a fake olympic gold medal right
this is your consolation prize yeah i
mean you don't
you don't get to that level in sports by
by getting a participation trophy and it
really it really felt like that
and and i've heard people say you know
that was really
the kind of the feeling overall um but
then he came in and he went
down the line he i believe he went in
reverse alphabetical order so
moffitt i was about in the middle of the
middle yeah
and was there anyone who didn't shake
his hand no not that i recall yeah
i i remember uh hearing jesse vasayo he
asked jessie vasayo
oh um how many medals would you have won
and jesse said i would have won two
golds and a silver
and he didn't ask anybody else that
question
yeah that just sucks the oxygen out of
the room yeah it's rough especially you
know jesse visaya was one of those
amazing talents that his window was 1980
yeah and even though he made it 84 he
just was a
he wasn't what he once was yeah he was
he was uh at mission viejo at its peak
when they were dominating
and he was the dominant swimmer yeah
yeah wild yeah
so you continue on um over the next
couple years you start to
uh develop this rivalry with with steve
lundqvist he's like your arch
nemesis in the 100 breaststroke uh well
at 200
strokes but he would take a crack at me
and he beat me i remember in 83 and i
was not pleased
uh-huh um you guys would go
mano amano all the time but he held the
world he
he set the world record and reset it a
bunch of times he did he did
i mean amano amano like is
he was he was dominant right and he he
was the one he was a mountain of a man
too
he was and he was just immensely
talented he was also a
really he is a very generous
uh competitor uh somebody who was always
collegial um and friendly
despite both of us knowing that we were
going for each other's jugular when it
came to
swimming next to each other in the park
well that gets played out
in 16 days of glory i mean that was a
you know very heartfelt moment
after the final but working up to that
you go to olympic trials in 1984
and you're the one who sets the world
record right
for the first time yeah you beat this
guy yeah and you go into the olympics as
the favorite in the hunter breast
the spotlight's on you you get up on the
blocks for
your qualifying heat right heat seven
what happens well it was
the night before was the opening
ceremonies and those of us who were
competing the next morning at 9 00 am
because that's when the preliminary
started we we opted not to go to the
opening ceremonies because
standing for right six eight hours
in a day the night before you compete is
you just don't do that
right you can't do that so we were
shaving down actually
and um lundqvist was your roommate he
was my roommate yeah so weird that they
would put you guys in the same room
it didn't seem weird at the time really
no it re it really didn't i know
i didn't have any problem with it i as
far as i know he didn't either
um but it wasn't just the two of us it
was several people in
in the same room oh okay yeah but but um
but yeah so we were shaving down the
night before and this was the
the one of the very first events of the
84 games
and you just you kind of don't know what
to expect but
some of the things that i remember were
getting into warm up and the stadium
which
i think it had a capacity of about 15
000 people
probably two-thirds were already there
by the time we were warming up
and i was introduced
um as i was getting ready to dive in
and it was just such a surreal
experience and
you know then the crowd reacts and i'm
like this is weird i've never
experienced anything like this before
um to say that i was um i was psyched
and ready to go is definitely an
understatement
it's a very strange thing that
i was i was never swimming faster in my
entire life
in the month it you know was a little
over a month i believe
between me breaking the world record at
the trials and then competing
at the games and the training i was i
was just
i was crushing fire i was on fire and i
had just
i knew i was on fire my body was just
working i felt good
um and i you know you don't really allow
yourself to think oh okay i've got this
because you don't you never do
but i was feeling really really good
like i was kind of pinching myself i was
feeling so good in the water
so i was ready for the uh prelims
and um and i
i usually don't remember my races
but for whatever reason i remember
thinking to myself
okay on that first 50 take it easy
whoa horsey you know and i just felt
great
and but i was i knew that i had needed
to
just really have that easy speed that
easy speed
it's and it's flying heat and as you
know that easy speed is elusive
but i had it and so i touched the 50
wall
and i came uh did my underwater pull and
keep in mind they're 15 000 people and i
don't think i'd ever competed
in front of that many people before and
i came up from my underwater poll
and the crowd like erupted
uh because i guess i was either at
or just below world record pace and i
wasn't
i wasn't going nearly yeah
it was it was yeah so it's like it was
like that that kind of
magic you know and then um i remember
thinking okay
get off my 50 wall and in breaststroke
and i would think you do with butterfly
that you you build off the wall you
don't just crank out a heart stroke
right off the wall you build
so i built you know usually was three
strokes for me
one two three and then on four i'm like
okay
let's bring it home i just wanted to
just kind of bring it home and it was
that fourth or fifth stroke
boom my leg just went i felt it go and
it was uh
a muscle called the adductor magnus
which is the big muscle
that uh basically closes your legs in
in your upper thigh on the inside i just
felt it go
you just tore it yeah you can see it
when you watch
the video there's a moment it's sort of
subtle but if you're looking for it you
can see it
and then suddenly it's a whole different
picture and you still
you end up pulling your way the rest of
it
to finish and you still one not only won
the heat but you set
the olympic record i did i did end up
dragging your legs
well those of us who have had like
sudden injuries and
i've had view too many of them that
there's a there's
adrenaline that kicks in and when you
first injure yourself you know you can
kind of you can kind of walk it off you
can and so
i even though i felt it go i i didn't
feel any diminishing strength
or or quickness at that point it was
that afternoon between preliminaries and
finals
where the inflammation kicked in and
where the blood started
you know bubbling up to the surface and
the bruising began that the pain really
started
um but i was i mean you've seen my
reaction at the end
of of the race i knew something was
terribly wrong um
but the pain didn't really start until
probably two or three hours later
when that's when that's when everything
collapsed and i was like oh no
this is this is a nightmare so you show
up for finals
six hours later did you you got a
cortisone shot
and and your leg is completely wrapped
in gauze
well the way the way it happened is once
again uh
i was in hell absolutely in hell and
i hadn't been able to talk to my parents
you know there weren't cell phones
my whole family was there and i remember
showing up
for the to warm up and
i just i don't i couldn't imagine
kicking breaststroke
like it was hard enough just to i
couldn't
even and i remember standing on the edge
of the pool and again
they announced me number one seed
olympic record holder he broke the
olympic record this morning
and world record holder john moffett is
getting in lane four whatever elena was
and like the the difference between
in the morning and that just incredible
bursting confidence that i had in the
morning was
completely deflated and non-existent and
i got in and i swam and i
did a 50 freestyle i'm like okay i
stopped at the other end of the pool and
i could actually see all the doctors and
the coaches there was there were several
of them four or five at the end of my
my lane and i remember pushing off the
wall and i'm like okay here it goes
let's see if i can kick breaststroke and
i couldn't
hmm this couldn't kick breaststroke i
just couldn't do it
so i got out after 100 and
my coaches and doctors pulled me aside
and said listen there's some things that
you can do
that we can do but you know if the risk
is high
you will certainly be injuring the
muscle
more but what they what they did is they
they said we can give you injections and
it wasn't cortisone it was uh it was
actually
um it was actually a local anesthetic
called xylocaine
believe that's the name of it and this
doctor took out
like these big syringes and just started
shooting xylocaine into this big muscle
in a very sensitive area
um so that i could you know if and i was
it was basically numb from my belly
button to my knee
within like 10 minutes so i had missed
warm up and
i mean i had to warm up so the women's
hundred free just happened
and before the medal ceremony they said
you can get in the diving well
and once again so they wrapped it very
tightly with basically
his adhesive tape they put some sort of
sticky stuff on they sprayed it on and
then
basically wrapped it in an adhesive tape
to hold the muscle together as much as
possible
and i got into the diving well which is
also within the stadium right it's right
there and you're the only one right
oh yeah there's nobody else on deck
there might be you know like a
you know an usher or something
there were probably half a dozen people
even on deck and so i knew every eye was
on me
including my parents and they didn't
know what's going on but
the the thing i remember is like okay
this is this is a moment
where i just don't want to regret this
moment
i don't want to regret it because as we
know regret is
something that's very difficult to live
with especially when it comes to
competition
like deciding not to do something but i
really couldn't kick breaststroke and
it was i just welled up every ounce of
strength that i could muster
and i kicked as hard as i could and i
screamed underwater because it just hurt
like hell
but every kick thereafter hurt a little
less
and i just i don't know how far i went
it probably wasn't very far i just
kicked and kicked and kicked and kicked
and it felt like a noodle
like you know what it's like to have a i
mean to have your lip numb
let alone have a little numb yeah it's
it's wow
so so i was able to kick enough where
okay
let's go and 15 minutes later i was on
the blocks
for the finals of the hundred
breaststroke and was there anything that
you did to kind of compose yourself
mentally and emotionally to
try to approach that mindset or you're
just
in the moment like taking it one second
at a time
when you're a competitor you get good at
masking
the way you're if you're feeling non not
confident
i was panicking it was completely
panicking yeah i was like
it's over it was embarrassing
um all the people that put so much into
helping me throughout my career
and it was just all came crashing down
and i also knew
there were i don't know hundreds of
millions
of people are watching it on tv so my
most
horrible personal defeat was unfolding
on
worldwide television yeah you know in
retrospect obviously there's nothing to
be embarrassed about you got injured
it's not like
you screwed up i would get embarrassed
when i wouldn't win
yeah it's just i think that's part of my
makeup but i don't remember
actually doing any sort of calming
uh-huh i just i was
i don't know what i looked like walking
out but i would think i had pretty much
of a poker face
yeah you did and i was one of those 100
some odd million people who watched it
live as it happened and i remember
vividly i think it was mark spitz who
when you took your sweatpants off and
everybody could see the
the bandaged leg he said something like
oh this is some kind of psychological
ploy like you're trying to play mind
games with lawn quest
or something and i was just thinking
nobody would do that
that's insane clearly there's something
very wrong here yeah yeah well
thankfully i couldn't hear his
commentary
um you get up on the blocks steve
lundqvist is
like in lane two right something like
that yeah yeah um
you're in the middle of the pool lane
for uh you end up
still pulling out like a fifth place
fashion this whole thing which is
insane to me that you weren't like 20
meters behind
everybody yeah i i remember i was
clearly last when i
at the turn i knew because when under
water pool you can you can see a fair
amount
and you take a glance where you are and
it was just not a custom
it wasn't something i was familiar
you're not i was used to i wasn't used
to
looking at the person beside me and
seeing their feet um
and i saw i knew i was in last and again
you know what creeped in it's like i
don't want to regret this i don't want
to regret this i want to be able to look
back
and no no that i tried as hard as i
could
that i welled up every possible fiber of
of strength and willfulness in order to
to get through this and i remember my
arms felt
great like i still had that right halo
of
my body feeling great and i just said
okay
legs legs are one's a noodle
just bring it home bring it home all
those pulling sets i did for years and
years and years now it's time they come
in handy and i just
i just used my arms and i i yeah i ended
up getting fifth but
but people who are familiar with
swimming you got to understand that
that of all um strokes breaststroke
you know the vast majority of your power
is coming from the legs yeah it was
probably about 70
of my stroke came from my kick yeah yeah
it's hard to even think about it now but
you can look back on that and know that
you gave it everything and and you know
that that image of lundqvist winning he
breaks the world record wins the gold
and then he comes over to your lane
and leans down and gives you a hug well
that's a relationship that we had
he he he was never anything but a
gentleman about
everything and humbled humbled by the
situation
uh and he made that very clear to me
but that wasn't the end of your career
so how do you pick the pieces back up
and try to rebuild after that
well i was on this fantastic team called
stanford
swimming i've heard of it yeah and
um you know we were we were on a roll so
this was
84 games were the summer between my
sophomore and junior year between my
second third year
so i had two more years of eligibility
and through various
flukes and disappointments and bad luck
we didn't win we although we were
favored my freshman and sophomore year
to win the national championships we
didn't florida ended up winning
so i had not only the
the goal ahead of me to win that team
national championship
but also a group of unbelievably
uh tough accomplished
men that were on the team who cared
about me
and who who wanted me to be part of
their team and i
desperately wanted to be part of their
team so i had this built-in support
network that's what people
maybe don't understand about a college
team is you have you have a support
network
and i i certainly had a great support
so i wanted to get back i i wanted to
get back
and try for that national championship
that eluded
us my freshman and sophomore year
i recall that it was probably about the
end of october beginning in november
before i got back in to swim
because the um the injury of my leg was
was pretty bad um the tear was severe
um and doctors really really didn't want
me to retear it they wanted to be sure
that it's 100 healed before i did any
breast stroke
so i really didn't get back into any
sort of meaningful training i think
until sometime
before thanksgiving so you know there's
like four or five months i took off
right right right um and
stanford does end up winning nc2as that
following year
it was awesome that 85 86 87
run i mean it was i mean
one of the greatest swimming franchises
of all time
i mean the talent on the stanford team
during that tenure was
unbelievable it really was unbelievable
and it wasn't lost on any of us i mean i
remember that objectively you could
you could take world rankings and you
can say there is no bigger concentration
of world-ranked swimmers on the planet
than at stanford in the mid-80s right
right i was you know admiring it from
afar
in the pages of swimming world magazine
which i would hotly anticipate you know
it's a rival in my mailbox pre-internet
and that was the only way to get any
kind of
news or information or inspiration about
what was going on
in the world of this sport because short
of olympic years
there's no real media coverage happening
so that was the one source of
trying to figure out what was happening
in this world and and
they would every year put on the cover
the team photo of the the team that i'd
won and i vividly remember that
uh year that you guys won the first time
and the
team photo and everybody there i was
just like that is the coolest thing man
like look at all of those guys they're
all like so extraordinary in their own
respective ways
it was cool yeah it was a
once-in-a-lifetime experience
so so yeah i mean there was more to me
as a swimmer and as an athlete than just
winning the olympic gold medal
um i would i would count the winning the
national championship as is as
just as elusive as as winning a gold
medal and just as difficult
of an endeavor um than olympic gold
medal but it's not looked upon the same
by the public right but it's
something that all of us who are part of
those teams
you know we we know we did something
because there was a
fantastic chemistry that existed and it
wasn't just the talent it was that
we all cared about each other and we all
had a good time
and swimming is hard especially you know
at a place
like well any college but a place like
stanford where so much has
has expected you above and beyond your
athletics
um i mean we we were we were really
close
and and that's the thing that i will
always carry with me it's not
the fact that we won the 1985 nc2a team
championship
in the 86 nc2a team championship it's
the guys who
i had the honor of of
swimming with my teammates right dave
bottom
dave bottom started it all yeah i mean
what a what a legend
that guy is i mean he when you look back
and you try to
you know deconstruct how
that team became what it is i mean he
really set the tone
i feel like he set in motion and kind of
cr
created the foundation and everything
built upon
like the tone that he set as as a leader
on that
on that squad it definitely extended
from him
he was he is of incredibly fun-loving
hard-working yeah
zest for life is not aptly
describing what he is like but just
incredibly passionate and talented
and jovial and good guy
so i remember arriving at the farm in
the fall of 1985
stanford just seemed like a fantasy land
to me it was so
outside the realm of anything that i
thought you know would be
accessible to me and when i got in i
just couldn't imagine not going
um but i was a walk-on you know i wasn't
somebody who was coveted or recruited
for the team
and i remember getting there early and
meeting dave bottom
and him being so genial and cordial to
me and inviting me to
go run stadium steps with him and i got
to know him before school even started
or
formal swim training started i met you
and i met some of these guys i mean i
was just like i couldn't believe that i
was actually meeting these guys who were
my heroes who then welcomed me into this
subculture that became so meaningful to
me
and i have vivid memories of of meeting
you early on and i remember
you were like you were a post grad at
that point so you weren't swimming on
the team but you were sticking around to
train
no first time the first year
that's correct um but
i was coming out of the school where you
just do what your coach
tells you to do and you're just training
four or five hours a day and putting in
massive volume and never questioning the
protocol
you were like uh
a strange animal that i'd never met
before who was
actually taking responsibility for your
own training and there would be
morning workouts that you wouldn't show
up for or you would say i'm not doing
stadiums
that's not good for me i know what i
need and i remember being very struck
by your um
your like confidence and
self-assurance about what was going to
work for you
and what wasn't which caused a lot of
strain
with it skipped the coach especially
early on
where's moffat call him like
but you knew what you needed and you
always performed when
when you needed to you know but i had
never seen that before
so walk me through a little bit about
that because i
i think that was unique in that time
that was you know to kind of like
um be your own guy yeah
you know certainly in hindsight with the
way the swimmers train now versus the
way we trained back then
um that's the you know that's the
backdrop
look i i went would go 20 000 meters in
a day
and i was a hundred breast joker my race
was about a minute long
or less like what am i doing looking
back on it it's insane
it is it is absolutely insane how much
i was expected to train and
it tore me to shreds it absolutely tore
me up i did not
have one of those bodies that could
withstand that kind of
punishment day in and day out right like
you read about phelps and how he could
recover
so he could handle that kind of volume i
couldn't and there were guys on that a
lot of guys on the team that could
i i couldn't and i knew that about me
and that and that that
that part about me was really sort of
solidified when i was in
high school i didn't i didn't do doubles
until i
up in even 1980 i didn't do double
workouts that's
crazy to me i didn't do double workouts
until
toward the end of my senior year in high
school and it was done because
i had some coaches who actually had some
vision
and some parents my parents who were
very supportive
but who clearly also had vision and they
didn't they didn't want to a
burn me out because i was i have a
personality type that
i i believe me i can get burnt out they
don't want to burn me out
and they didn't want to just tear me
apart at like 14 15 years old like
so many of the kids were already having
a problem with i mean what what's the
attrition
and swimming it's like in in the teens
early early to mid teens
and and so i also shared like i was like
you know swimming can write me a ticket
somewhere i don't know exactly where but
i can write me a ticket somewhere
because i was just kind of a normal kid
but i was really good at swimming
and so i didn't even start weights until
college
um i i would do which is also crazy
because you were always super jacked
well that's the reason i didn't have to
do weights yeah
i mean look i knew i knew one guy's got
much bigger calves than me
[Laughter]
yeah well i wish they were a bit smaller
but i always
i mean that's a whole nother topic of
people walking up to your grocery store
and saying what do you do to get such
big calves
i don't mean to digress but my heavens i
would i really don't like them very much
they don't fit in jeans you can't wear
decent jeans they're all show no go
pants don't fit
they don't they don't yeah so okay so we
digressed what were we talking about
you didn't touch weights until college
yeah um and even even
a little bit in high school my senior
year i would do like speed circuit stuff
i would do like
one of the things i would do is i would
do squat jumps isokinetics squat jumps
that was the closest thing that i did to
weights and then
skip also realized that i did not need
to do heavy weights especially
my freshman year i didn't do heavy
weights
maybe my sophomore year i began to do
more heavyweights
because my i actually kept growing in my
freshman year in college
and um and so i would do
uh plyometrics early before anybody knew
what plyometrics were
which is basically spending as little
time on the ground as possible and
jumping you know using using your pure
fast twitch muscle fiber
and i would do reaction drills like dave
bottom and i would do reaction drills
where
we would have our eyes closed and you
know we somebody would say
you know go and you'd open your eyes and
you'd have to hit whatever it is
you know just like really neurological
like
like teaching your body how to react in
an explosive way
that was much more important to me than
being physically strong
because i that was not my problem and
and you know as as i'm sure you're well
aware
swimming in a world-class environment
with really good swimmers you realize
what your weaknesses are
very very quickly and you know what your
strengths are
and so i always had the philosophy it's
like i really needed to focus on
on my weaknesses things that i really
really could improve
because me getting incrementally
stronger was not going to make me a
better swimmer right and
thankfully i was surrounded by people
who agreed with me on that topic yeah
well you were way ahead of the curve
because now that's standard protocol for
swim training i mean
it's changed so much yeah i mean you
know for people who are unfamiliar it
really was
just get in the pool and churn out these
sets up to 20 000 yards
or meters every single day four or five
hours of pool time
a couple weight sessions a week and
you know live your life as a zombie like
from 15 to 21
you know it's like it's all a fog
because you're
so exhausted all the time and you're
banking
that when you finally back off and
undertake that two-week taper that
you're going to bounce back completely
and be at your peak and
it's just crazy when you think about
that in the context of a race that
lasts 49 seconds or or 18 seconds you
know if you're swimming the 50 freestyle
yeah that you would be doing that the
sport
i don't know how in touch you are now
with kind of training modalities
but only a little bit it's pretty crazy
like i
i've i've popped into the um
the post-grad workout at usc a couple
times over the
last couple years conor dwyer invited me
to to join them i've only gone a couple
times but
this is where a bunch of you know very
accomplished
um post-collegiate swimmers go to train
for
the next olympics like lock to use
training there and stuff like that
um or ban check was his coaching he's
like
my favorite coach yeah i was so lucky to
have been able to be coached under him
and i was how
amazing and phenomenal was that guy he
was amazing still at it
you know it's crazy and
the workout resembled nothing like
anything i was familiar with
you know when you get in you're putting
like you're putting like
nets on your feet and you're just doing
12 and a halfs and turning around and
all this like
short sprint you know learning how to
explode off the walls like it was all
bursts and power which was completely
different than the way that we trained
i wish i would have been able to train
like that but you would have benefited
tremendously
when you look at the times you know now
and how much they've dropped i mean
clearly they've figured out something
that
we didn't know i i'm convinced i was in
a perpetual state as i guarantee you
were and
all of the swimmers in a perpetual state
of being overtrained
yeah unless you're that rare freak like
that michael phelps who has that
um biology that allows them to flush the
lactate acid out quickly and recover
more rapidly but i i would
venture to say that you know 85
of elite swimmers were over trained
during that era
for sure yeah i was wonderful yeah
well you still you i mean by taking
control you were able to create your own
trajectory in your own
your i was an expat don't go thinking i
was in complete control no i mean
i mean there were a lot of knock down
drag outs yeah
yeah i i wouldn't i would say i got a
lot of
uh a lot of resistance from my teammates
who are able to withstand the punishment
a little bit more readily than i was
able to and though
those were the ones i knew skip was
going to give me grief no matter what
because that's his job job of a coach is
to push you harder than you think you
should go
and so i understand i understood that
type tightrope but having
you know my peers and my teammates you
know like saying you know we're
questioning
whether or not you're you're you're
dedicated i'm like you're kidding me
right
you know it's like that hurt right right
right um
but i wasn't the only one i mean dave
bottom was
he was he he was the one that he was cut
from that mold too yeah he was yeah for
sure
yeah yeah well that was that must have
been good giving you some comfort
because
you know he kind of established that you
could do that
yeah i think for some reason i don't
think skip got as mad at him as he got
at me
yeah i think what i think where it
started is my freshman year you know he
would
he would call me in the morning morning
workouts and i'd wake up my
roommates and they'd be all pissed off
and i just realized like hey i can pull
this
i can pull the plug out of this thing
and then of course
your phone that made him really bad
you didn't answer your phone yeah it's
like oh sorry yeah
let's just say skip was prone to
explosive
moments over the years he was amazing
for me
he was very very good for me and his
drill sergeant
mentality really
that that's what he's known for but
what he did for me was realize that the
team was
bigger than what i was doing and that we
couldn't achieve
ourselves without the team thriving
as well and that was a mantra right i
mean
from the marines i'm sure it's like
you've gotta you know when you're in
combat you have to
you have to react as a team you know
each other's backs
and and i think that in that respect
certainly in those eras era from well
the mid
mid 80s and then the 90s to about
2000 was his last and yeah like that
suited him very very well because what
he did was he created
teams that were really really close
and you don't win national championships
unless you're really close
that was his greatest talent i mean i
you know skip is a flawed individual i'm
not sure he was the best coach for me or
that the program was you know wasn't
suited for me i wasn't
gonna be a point scorer but um
but he was incredibly talented at
trying to create that alchemy that made
everybody work in unison when you
come from club swimming it's like it's
an inherently individual sport
then i go to stanford and it's all about
team
and i just fell in love with that it all
became about how can we
cohere as a group of individuals to work
together and you could feel it there was
something very special about that
yeah i mean i think it's and it's it's
illustrated i have uh two photographs
from that era that
are up in my house the first er first
photograph
is a kind of a ragtag group of us in
we um we assembled in front of memorial
church in the quad it was a blazingly
hot day
with uh president kennedy who was then
the president of
stanford university he just passed away
like within a year ago like
actually i think like a couple months
ago not pretty recently
he was amazing he he he was amazing he
was incredibly supportive of his student
athletes and
he um he was in a suit and tie
and like i said and we were all in our
speedos yeah so we were fine i mean it
was like 100 degrees it was crazy hot
and so we took the picture and
i i remember he said tell you what if
you win next year
you uh you wear the suit and tie and all
wear the speedo
and we're like all right done yeah well
a year later we went again which you're
in that picture
in that photo and we're all in our suits
and ties i don't remember it being
especially hot that day so he missed out
and and and president kennedy the
president of stanford university is
there in the middle of speedo with a
speedo yeah yeah yeah yeah
but the but the thing about those
photographs that
i didn't notice it until years and years
and years later is you know who's
missing in those photographs
i don't know skip i never thought of
that
skip's missing and you know why and i've
never asked him about this
but i think this was our victory this is
his job
to coach us to victory this is our
victory
and i would be really surprised if you
were to ask him today whether or not
that was a conscious decision
i think i think it was and and certainly
i believe the intentionality all
symbolizes
the way he looked upon his role on the
team was that it was his job
but it was our victory yeah i've never
reflected on that before
that's a very good point yeah he said to
me one time
there was a moment of strife i think it
had to do with him and dave shraven
going head-to-head with each other
him like screaming at dave and dave
storming off the pool deck or something
like that
and it was a crack in the armor in the
kind of unity of the team
you could feel it and skip said to me
afterwards
you know if if if it takes
uh you guys hating me for us to win
i'm willing to do that and i remember
just feeling very conflicted about that
on the one hand that's a level of
self-sacrifice that i guess i can
appreciate
but i just didn't feel like that was the
productive healthy path forward
that's interesting that you had that
reaction because i always assumed that
that was the same
that was the equation i know i don't
think i ever
thought anything that he he was
perfectly comfortable and at ease with
us
not like not liking him and i think not
liking him galvanized us
in many ways right it would as opposing
forces
in its in in its antipathy towards the
coast well don't you think that that's
like not
i don't know when you look at like the
way that pete carroll coaches the
seahawks or like this
this sort of or you know this this more
evolved
kind of uh sensei zen master approach to
coaching where you're trying to bring
out the best in the individual
yeah there has to be you know a belief
in
you know that potential right like a
there's a there's a trust there it's a
very that's a very different thing
clearly but yeah it's all at the same i
mean you're all trying to do the same
thing and coaches
have different styles objective is
different yeah i mean the object the
objective is the same right
yeah you want to you want to win you
want you want your athletes to
be champions and to win and and i think
the best coaches also want your athletes
to be happy
and also uh succeed in life not just
in the athletic endeavor yeah yeah yeah
and i i
guarantee you he feels that way yeah so
if you were to
find yourself coaching the stanford
swimming team
what would be your ethos i haven't even
thought about it because there's no way
in the world i would want to do that
oh gosh i don't i don't know i i don't
think i've even developed that part of
my brain
i mean the the whole athlete side of me
is such a stranger to me
it's it's so long ago um i have a hard
time even picturing
myself as doing that and being able to
withstand
you know how difficult it was yeah and
the pressures and and
all of that yeah so yeah i don't want to
cop out of
your question but i just i have no idea
how i'd go about that
i remember after you graduated and you
were still sticking around and doing
some training at some point
you got recruited by usa cycling yeah
to get on the bike and give it a try
somebody saw your your calves and your
legs and thought this guy might be good
on a bike
yeah yeah they threw me on well you went
out to like the olympic training center
right i did i spent three months at the
olympic training center was that for
uh was that for like velodrome racing it
was road cycling
it was it was the national development
team and it encompassed both
uh road cycling and velodrome cycling
but back then
the uh the velodrome was out outdoors
right
now it's covered it's in a big bubble
but back then it was outdoors
and you you couldn't ride a velodrome
when there's ice
everywhere so i only had the opportunity
to ride on that velodrome
a few times but we were training like a
lot of the people that i was training
with
um i was in a more more
sprint-track-oriented type of
you know group but several of those guys
made the 88 team that i was
i was training with wow so what was that
like when you just suddenly
decided to jump into a brand new sport
and you're with some of the elites
i i just don't i just don't know where i
got the hutzpah
uh-huh i really don't i remember you're
able to mix it up pretty good or was it
not at first
not at first i will remember
that i ended up showing up in the middle
of the night
uh it was a really snowy night and it
was just dumping
and so i think i got in somewhere around
like 10 o'clock at night 11 o'clock at
night
and they dropped me off at the olympic
training center in front of these
barracks like
housing yeah and they gave me okay this
is your key this is your room number
buy and i have all my bikes and and i
like kind of walk in and i can hear down
the hall there's a tv
and it's really quiet and
i walk in and there's this big giant
dude and i've got all my bike gear and
everything and i was like
hey wondering where i could put my bikes
and it was this guy named ken carpenter
and ken carpenter was a
match sprinter of he was a world-class
match sprinter
i can't recall whether or not he
actually won a medal but he he went he
went to the 1988 olympic games in
matches sprinting
and he was he immediately took me under
his wing and i realized that
you know athletes are they they they
want to have each other's backs
but i remember falling asleep that night
and my roommate was already asleep
and i'm like this is the weirdest thing
i've ever done yeah
i have no idea what i'm in for but kind
of badass
i don't know seriously what gave me the
hubris
well i mean eric hayden had kind of set
that precedent right and eric was
at st at stanford medical school at the
time right did you ever meet him or talk
to you
about it yeah yeah i did i rode with him
a few times and
the thing is he had a lot more saddle
time than me at this point you know i've
been
actively writing and training for maybe
six months
um and and i remember getting up the
next morning and it was like a
clear day in colorado springs but
there's about hip deep snow uh-huh
and i meet my roommate awkwardly a few
years this guy sleeping next to me i've
never met him i'm gonna have to live
with him for the next three months
and and so and it was run back then by a
group of
uh polish guys um and the
the main guy is a guy named eddie eddie
b eddie eddie
boroshevitz i think was his last name
but we all called him eddie b
and volter and he
they they ran it like an eastern bloc
country
and i remember him getting in front
there's about there was about 80 or 90
of us
and i didn't know anybody and i remember
very clearly
eddie b getting in front of everybody
goes okay guys today
it's snow day and everyone's like yeah
thanks
and today we place no soccer
no rules
it was just a disaster what does that
mean well we would go
we went out on the we went out on the
field which was in the middle of the
olympic training center back then
and like i said it was hip deep snow and
he gave us a soccer ball
and we divided us up into teams and
we're supposed to score a goal somehow
and it was just and it was such a great
way for me
to get my bearings because i realized
that
you know these people are not supreme
soccer players
they they were great athletes on the
bike
and we just laughed and and you know the
thing well i'm still lifelong friends
with one of the guys i was there
with and we recall you know we kicked
the ball and you couldn't see the ball
right well then some smart alec got the
idea well i'm just gonna pick it up and
run with it because there's no rules
right so eddie b blows his whistle he
goes guys guys come on one rule
you know and obviously the rule is we
need to kick the ball
but that was i remember that kind of
eased me into things but i got
i got dropped on my first real ride
um it was like a 90 or 100 mile ride
and i got dropped
like i mean i had never it was
humiliating
um where one of the coaches had to
actually take the back of my
saddle and grab onto the back of my
saddle and catch me up to the group
and i remember getting up to 65 miles an
hour and i'm like
i'm terrified yeah and that's the other
thing about cycling as you know
because you and i both have had our fair
amount of tumbles
that there's a fear is a he doesn't
exist in swimming like it does in
cycling
yeah yeah yeah i mean you have to have
complete balls and be totally unafraid
on these descents like it's
it's death defying i was afraid yeah
yeah and if you
if you have any fear at all like that's
the edge that's going to prevent you
from moving forward
but how long did you do that before did
you reach i mean you got to a certain
point right
yeah you had to make a decision am i
going to continue with this or not well
that post-grad
i had a i had a series of crashes i
realized that
you know the bike handling was
definitely an issue for me and i
remember in spring i had a i had a lulu
of a crash
um and but i did end up making national
the national time cut
for the kilo um and i i
kind of was at one of those junctures
it's like
okay do i keep training i
still had it in me something a fire
still burned and
i thought well can i make 88 and cycling
no way maybe 92 if i
you know if i dedicated myself to it but
i didn't want to wait five years
now i i i didn't want to time to call
bud greenspan
yeah so working on a new path well and
what i ended up doing is i ended up
training for 88
and and that didn't work out well either
lived with pablo and
right and trained with uh you know with
uh some really really good athletes and
it just didn't
it just didn't work out mm-hmm yeah i
mean that was
that was probably a study in
overtraining right
that was a little cohort that was the
hardest i'd ever trained in my entire
life and i'm thinking to myself i was
like 20 what was like 24 years old
and i remember thinking to myself why am
i training harder now than i when i was
16.
um but i just wanted it so badly and i
and i just you just get caught up in the
whole thing you know pablo morales who
was the world record holder he was
trying he was
he he'd gone undefeated basically i mean
he was the most winningest
nc2a swimmer of all time all the time
still is just a foregone conclusion that
he was gonna make the team in multiple
events and be the team captain
well that's what he was doing and i kind
of got swept up in it you know where
i had this sort of inner john barometer
it's like okay i'm way over trained
right now or i'm
i need to recover or i didn't i ignored
that this time because i got swept up in
the whole thing it's like i want this so
bad i want this so bad
you know and that was a really really
bad thing to do like mistake wanting
something so bad
for doing something that you know is bad
for you
because i knew i i just felt i just i
was getting sucked down the drain
um and i could feel it it actually
started in the in the fall
and i just never i never recovered and
unfortunately
there's a whole bunch of us who ended up
getting sucked down the drain as well
and we just we it was it was a disaster
of a year for so many of us that we're
training i actually quit the program and
went back and trained with skipping
stanford yeah well i think
what's instructive about that is is this
idea
that okay well it's game on we're gonna
put all our chips on the table we're
going to live like
monks we're going to cloud out
everything and we're just going to push
ourselves beyond anything that we've
ever
you know experienced before and that
will reap the result that we seek and it
doesn't work that way
no it doesn't it doesn't and but it's
easy to talk yourself into that
especially when you've got a group think
mentality like you do
in certain teams this team wasn't we
weren't we weren't
bonded like we were like the stanford
team you know where you felt comfortable
enough
going against the coach or something
like that oh and it was you know led to
my ruin
as far as that 1988 goes as far as my
swim career in 88
so when you reflect back on your career
now i mean you said
in 84 you didn't want to have any
regrets i mean do you have regrets or
what is your relationship to
to your career thankfully i don't yeah i
don't i think the
the closest thing that i have to
any sort of what if but it's not a
regret
was in 1992 i believe it was late 1991
and i we i did the stanford alumni meet
and i was i don't know what got into me
but i i started swimming
and i got i was swimming so fast and i
remember this
i was i was like i couldn't believe it
you thought i thought 84 i was swimming
fast i was swimming
way faster and there was a rule change
in breaststroke so i started playing
with that stroke and i was
right barryman had kind of
revolutionized the rhythm and the
technique
right so i kind of studied that and it
started to click and i mean i was just
absolutely hauling and that like i said
i think it was 1991
would have been like october of 1991.
and
uh pablo was there and i ended up like
basically going about the fastest 50 i'd
ever gone including
in college and just i mean
just was hauling ass off how much
training not very much like
3 000 yards three times a week
that's nothing yeah but it just goes to
show you how over trained we were
right and how we weren't really using
our brains i mean you're such a
racehorse too like you're a guy who can
walk away and then come back
and just dip your toe in it a little bit
and then suddenly you're
at a razor's edge and i know this from
seeing
you you kind of you you go through these
spurts where you're into master swimming
and then you'll disappear for a while
and then you come back
and it's like you come back and you're
kind of like you know not looking so
great and then like a week later you're
like doing world record splits
like a master's workout look those days
are long over rich i mean please come on
um but are we back to my regret there um
the only the closest thing to
it was i would call it a what if not a
regret was at that
meet pablo
unbeknownst to me at that point would i
had already started training
for 1992 uh because you know
like i said earlier pablo morales the
world record holder the favorite
no one thought he could lose didn't make
the team in 1998
or 1988 yeah and he said
what do you think about training for
and i i remember in the back of my mind
i was swimming so fast i kind of like
i let that fantasy kind of
sink in like so that's one of the
reasons that i think i actually
trained a little bit so that i could see
what i could do at that alumni meet
so obviously that was kind of in the
back of my mind
but i had this overwhelming dread of the
thought
of getting back into the pool and in
being as dedicated as i needed to be
in order to make that 1992 team
and i remember when he asked me come
come on train and he asked me you know
he
asked me several times and i remember
each time i got more and more resolute
that i don't have it in me
i just don't have it in me so you know
part of me is phys
physically i think perhaps it could have
been
something that could have happened in
1992 games and and
you know just to remind your listeners
that pablo morales ended up winning
two gold medals in the 1992 olympics
right
and it was redemption for him it was one
of the greatest moments in
olympic swimming history i mean he he
doesn't make it in 88
is like all right i'm done goes to law
school does two years at cornell law
school
goes home for family reasons and decides
to
you know stick around at home which is
right
nearby the stanford campus right starts
kind of dipping his toe in the pool and
showing up at the noon
masters workout and before you know it
kind of under wraps he starts training
again
makes the olympic team goes and beats
was it anthony nesty that he beat and
barcelona for the 100
i don't remember i do remember it was
barcelona yeah it was barcelona
um just one of the greatest comebacks
ever for sure
for sure and you know his mother had
just passed away the previous year
so there was a lot there was a lot to it
he had a lot invested
personally and and he pulled it off
which is
i mean cajones like serious
serious stuff that he was able to do
that because that's difficult
and i just was not convinced that i had
it in me
yeah and if you have that doubt i mean
you got to be all in
right right and it was one of those
things you know you ask about regret and
it's like
you know i think about it from time to
time do awake regret not doing that no
because um i felt very confident that i
just didn't have it in me
right i didn't want to i i i had already
decided i wanted to reinvent myself
yeah at that point which you did you go
on to win
three emmys how many emmys have you won
three but
it was many years later yeah yeah um
how many olympic athletes have emmys i
don't know probably not very many
yeah i couldn't tell you um but this
begins
somewhat humbly in the early days of
reality tv
when reality tv wasn't quite what it is
now i mean now we live in a reality tv
world of course but
you start out at hard copy which was
kind of like an extra type
investigative slash entertainment news
show that would air like every night
and then you end up at uh at the working
as a executive producer at the amazing
race uh i wasn't an executive producer
and that was all so many many years
later
i was at the amazing race but um you
know i started out
um it was a stanford alum rolled the
dice and letting me
write um a series for discovery channel
way in the early days this was
this was around 1992 that i was i got to
write this
this series and um and then that's what
led me
ultimately to realizing that i love
telling stories
um i never in a million years thought
that i would make my living being a
writer i don't
like writing i really i just don't like
the process of writing
but people kept hiring me to write and
then that ultimately led me to
land the position in a hard copy which
back then was
nobody knew quite what it was they
called it tabloid tv but it was part
news but they also broke many many many
of the biggest stories of that era
michael jackson being one of them they
were there on the forefront of
o.j simpson um so and that was the era
that i was in it was this very strange
place to be but i'll tell you that we
mentioned adam ram
he was just one of them it was of all
the crews that i've ever been part of
collectively that was the most
intelligent group
just whip smart that's street smart i
wouldn't have thought that
so smart like you
you never doubted the intellectual
capacity of any of these people it was
crazy
wow yeah so how long were you at hard
cops i was there for about
three and a half years yeah and you know
i
i got into the director's guild because
they started having me direct
shows or direct episodes and i found my
niche
you know my niche really wasn't i
actually worked on the tonya
hurting story oh you did yeah um
in what way i was the i believe
my title back then i don't know if i was
on the director's guild but maybe i was
i was
maybe directed by i directed the the
episodes
so in itanya the movie you know they
have the yeah
they have the hard copy guy i remember
that
they didn't they didn't do their
research because it was actually me it
was you
i mean there were people out in the
field yeah but i i was the one
responsible for staying up all night and
cutting the stories together and making
sure that it hit the satellite the next
day
for air yeah um and and i kind of found
my
niche my niche was not necessarily oj or
michael jackson or
although i did lend a hand if they
needed you know to to
do some shooting or writing or whatever
my my niche was kind of like a funny
little niche that i
thoroughly enjoyed which was paranormal
i love the paranormal stories
i love the paranormal stories ufo ghosts
all that stuff like foot i just love
bigfoot we
want probably the most infamous and one
of my favorite
bigfoot or paranormal stories i ever did
was a bigfoot story about a playboy
playmate
who was on a shoot and she was in her
motorhome and bigfoot walked in front of
her it was all on camera
and and i remember we called it playmate
and the primage
it was so it was just it was like tongue
firmly and
yeah and cheek so much of it it was more
innocent of a time and i also approached
it i i realized that
i had a knack for kind of like figuring
out what stories were all about and the
way i looked at these is like a campfire
story you know you don't you don't want
it too long
and you want to be able you want to go
someplace and you want to deliver you
know and these paranormal stories are
like that
i also they would send me on all the
extreme stuff like i would every every
spring they would send me out to chase
tornadoes and uh-huh
so there were that's fun there were
there was a there was a lot of i mean i
did get a lot of gratification i
ultimately
it wasn't for me there was kind of a
self-selection i wasn't happy there
yeah um and so i ended up doing uh
network specials after that
um i remember though so i got that job
at the law firm
and i quickly was miserable
suffering and occasionally i'd go to the
paramount lot and go
see you and it just looked like so much
fun compared to
my day-to-day experience it was like a
big it was like a big rumpus room
you know we were a whole we encompassed
like a huge portion of the sound stage
it was just we called it the bullpen and
it was like
you know there's the assignment desk and
then there were the segment directors
and then there were the
the you know it was everybody was all in
one place
so it was it was always just this like
fever pitch of activity um just
in in the energy you know in fact i
you know i i had to put headphones on so
i could concentrate because it was so
loud
um and there's so many distracting
things happening
all at once when you look at news today
and the kind of reality tv nature the
performance
aspect of what the news cycle has become
you know do you reflect back upon those
hard copy days and see
you know how a ends up at z
i do and i feel bad about that
that i do believe that that this was the
very beginning of
of kind of like really taking
not being completely objective and
taking a perspective
because it a lot of a lot of the stories
had perspective but a lot of the stories
had
had a lot of newsworthiness right as
well fundamentally it was this news
entertainment hybrid right where it was
like it was about
like how can we get people engaged as
my time going on it went from pretty
much a
a news magazine show a daily news strip
magazine show to
at the end and i think this is one of
the things that made me
uh realize that it's not for me it
became more and more
and more like entertainment tonight
uh-huh you know it was more
entertainment-based celebrity-based and
i just
i was i just was i knew that wasn't for
me right you just you just become
like a publicity adjunct of the studios
at that point
feeding up whatever narrative they want
about the next movie or tv show
yeah i mean i it was an amazing life
experience but
it's not necessarily a chapter that i
would like hold up and
right you know oh it's one of the
highlights something i'm very
you know just super proud of
accomplishing it's not like that
so how do you end up at the amazing race
uh
well i saw the show uh the promos for
the show it was 2001.
i called the amazing race and i'm like i
love that
show i love that show i want to work on
that show
so quick short history i believe they
aired one episode
and then 9 11. and so the
the show was basically it was put on the
shelf
because nobody wanted to see a race
around the world for a million dollars
after what happened in new york city on
9 11.
but i also figured out like it's almost
like all roads lead to hard copy
one of my co-workers at hard copy was
the executive in charge of production
at the amazing race and
i got in touch with him and he ended up
returning
my phone call saying you just missed it
you would be perfect here
but basically we've just hired everybody
for season two but i'll remember you for
season three
so it was that guy who remembered me
when they were
coming around for season three and
hiring for season three and i got hired
on season three
um you know season season three
um excuse me if it's a little bit fuzzy
it was
almost 20 years ago it's crazy
um but you know season season three was
a fantastic season
and what they did is they immediately
picked up a season four
um and so i was i finished up i think in
like november or something
and then i had to be back boots on the
ground at first week in
january and so then we did season four
and um they didn't air it they didn't
air season three
and we're all thinking to ourselves oh
gosh it's doomed
they didn't air the entire season yeah
they well they they just they've held it
they just held it wow but
some strange things happen a strange
confluence of we talk about luck and
luck
playing into our own little successes
and
failures and our our lives and
what happened was they held that until
the summer
which back then conventional wisdom was
if you air something in the summer
you're putting it
you're basically putting it out to
pasture to die slow death
silently without much notice
but a strange thing happened is that
people started watching survivor which
was the sister show
and programmers and networks started
realizing that
much of this they underestimated how
much pent-up demand there was in the
summer for new programming
burnett wasn't behind amazing racism
right it was what's the
first monster yeah yeah i could i was
like i knew he had a crazy name yeah i
met that guy a couple
i mean he's a character yeah yeah yeah
yeah there's
and i worked with him quite a bit i
worked with him on subsequent projects
as well so
um but uh but so we were like
doing season four and actually the
morale was pretty bad
because we knew that they weren't airing
season three
in the fall because no i guess that
would have been that would have been the
winter
they weren't going to air it in the in
no in the spring i'm sorry that
the cycle they didn't air it in the
spring season three even though it was
all on camera
working on four and you're on four and
we're like it's dead yeah it's dead and
they
so sure enough they put it out to
pasture
um and uh and then they aired that
summer
in the summer of must have been 2003
they aired that summer and it was just
it just crushed it
not only did the viewers love it and got
great ratings but the critics just raved
and that's the first year it won the
emmy um
and let me tell you it was just a
furious pace after that
um and uh i didn't win for season three
or i wasn't
i i would even though i was i was
technically called a show producer
i was responsible for two episodes in
the entire season
um that's just the way it all worked out
because you you had to put it together
so quickly
so i wasn't eligible because it said
show in front of producer
yeah um so then uh the next season
that i did um i was supervising producer
yeah and then then they then then that's
that's what led to that freight train
of being able to or gravy train whatever
you want to call it
of being able to be swept up in this
whole emmy craze
world yeah i mean it was a phenomenon
and it's like this perfect confluence of
your talents like you
have the storytelling thing you had cut
your teeth in television you understood
what
makes for a good narrative but you also
have the athlete and the
competitor mindset that allows you to
kind of
cut to like what's going to work here
and what's not
it was hard yeah i'll i'll tell you that
maybe exciting though
you know as you know i mean i'm sure
people look at your life go oh man it
must have been so exciting to
do all these first-time feats and things
like that
as you know it's gnarly you know and
there's a lot of moments where you're
left alone inside your head and
you know like what people what people
don't
always necessarily realize is that
you know you have these accomplishments
and people like to celebrate
accomplishments and others but what you
don't necessarily realize is that there
are no
photographs or videos or mementos of
those hard times
those inevitable hard times that it
takes of that relentless work that it
takes to get there
because without exception in order to do
things
that are big like that it takes an
enormous personal sacrifice and an
enormous amount of personal dedication
and hard work in order to get there
and then where luck plays into it is bad
luck in
my case in 1984 and good luck in my case
for the amazing race
that yeah but the the concurrent
like through line is you keep showing up
right
oh yes that's with that mindset like all
those tools that you learned
as a competitor as a swimmer come into
play in the professional world
that i can't imagine you must be sitting
on thousands and thousands and thousands
of hours of footage
and and tasked with trying to figure out
how to
you know create something special out of
what's just raw footage
of people cruising around yeah the
season four i was uh responsible for the
for the premiere episode um
and the premiere episode has the most
teams has the most work
moving parts it also has just by nature
of being the first episode it's got a
lot of things that
tend to go sideways
and you know you need to do a lot of
workarounds but i remember
that um of just raw footage that went
into that
i believe we we would cut that to be 90
minutes so
the clock it would be somewhere around
an hour and
four minutes i think so to make that
90 minute air time we had over 100 hours
of raw footage
and you just couldn't do this show there
was there was no
you they didn't the digitizing process
was completely different back then we
watched on vhs
wow like you got really good at
shuttling vhs
um and you had you you were responsible
for
everything that was on those tapes you
needed to know it inside and out in just
the log books after log books just the
amount of resource that it took
just to absorb what happened because
these cameras and sound people would go
out with these teams and it would be
could be a void it'd be like radio
silence you wouldn't know what was
happening i don't know what's going on
right
yeah you had interviews you know at the
end of the day
but you truly don't know what's going on
with each team until you
watch everything unfold moment by moment
and that was i think probably like just
so daunting to put these things together
and you're right it's like how do you
how do you take 100 hours of raw footage
and make it into
something that tens of millions of
people will tune in and celebrate
um it was it was rewarding yeah
yeah but it was it was so hard right
yeah i remember moments over the years
where you
were completely burned out on oh yeah
yeah yeah oh
i i definitely burnout was probably my
biggest
enemy and i think ultimately i couldn't
withstand just the
unpleasant the inherent unpleasantness
of the entertainment business that you
just have to deal with on a day-to-day
basis
to varying degrees doesn't mean i wasn't
on shows that were just there that were
absolute joys
there were certainly those but um but
yeah it just it just wore me down
um in the way that that hard copy was
very much a progenitor of
of what news looks like now um how do
you think about
you know what the reality tv reality
kind of
lifestyle that we all live on like you
know now it's youtube and vlogging and
like everything is reality tv i mean you
were
you know early on like that was the
first wave
of this kind of programming finding its
way to network and now
it's just you know atmospheric
everywhere you turn it's ubiquitous
isn't it yeah yeah and it's certainly
continuum i mean you can you can
you can trace back that continuum to
those days when
you know when reality tv was ultimately
really sort of
embraced by a guy named mike darnell
right
that's right he was the he was the guy
who really understood
right absolute genius too don't don't
think it's only blind luck that got him
to where it was also he's
absolutely brilliant hmm um
do you watch reality tv now i don't i've
never really never been interested in it
i and that was that's great that was
maybe
i i need to i need to throw out a caveat
to that i'm interested in real stories
and reality tv is basically
highly produced yeah storytelling say
the least yeah
and although i do i would agree with
that but during quarantine
i mentioned this on an earlier podcast
but our family
we would have uh after dinner we would
watch queer eye
which is fantastic i know i know so fun
yeah yeah anyway go ahead
come on you had to do tiger king oh well
yeah we did that
of course everybody did tiger yeah but
that was a that was a docu-series
well still reality tv
all right you know those those those
stories the guy who's who's who's been
behind the curtain
there's you know so when you see
something like that you're like oh i see
what they're doing here no not always
but sometimes i do yeah sometimes they
do it just takes a great deal of work i
mean
what you're doing is the story is
already there like in the raw footage
the story is already there you just need
to sculpt it out
and figure out how to tell it because
that's that's what editing is right it's
compressing time and it's compressing
moments in order to
make something more meaningful because
like the passage of a story is painfully
slow and it's certainly not ready for
something like a half hour of television
or an hour of television
vision much less you know 40 seconds of
a youtube
right so it's it's it's all compressed
exaggerated of course
yeah of course um all right well let's
pivot the last thing i want to
explore with you is um the work that you
that you do with respect to the olympic
movement i know you're really involved
in
the paralympic movement and the olympic
movement and la24 and all that kind of
stuff so
what does that look like well in it was
2007 and
like i said earlier i i kind of
consciously turned my back on
on all things olympic uh athletics
wouldn't consider myself necessarily a
sports aficionado however i am and
i love athletes i love the stories of
athletes and
it doesn't mean i don't watch sports but
i'm not like an avid like football
basketball
you know what i mean that's that's not
you're like me i love the olympics and i
like watching the tour de france yeah oh
gosh is that like
the greatest thing weird i know you're
into formula one yeah right right
weird sports yeah except in the rest of
the world
uh-huh they're weird right yeah exactly
the rest of the world is not weird yeah
um so how i got how i got
i kind of reluctantly got sucked into
being uh serving on aboard the board of
of the southern california olympians and
paralympians association which is
is in essence the alumni group for
olympians and paralympians in southern
california it's the biggest and oldest
chapter in the country
and uh the president then asked me to
be on the board um and i was
it was kind of like i was definitely
reluctant i was kind of like oh
i don't know about this and so
i started doing some work and i kind of
enjoyed it
and there was a there was a familiarity
and a joy
that in a source like it was it was like
getting back to my roots like
when i would hang out with these people
these people who
we might not have been on this exact
same teams but we have a shared
we have this shared parallel experience
oftentimes very separate
but we all know what we there's there's
a there's a real bond
there's a real bond in that and it's
really fun and it's
it's also a kind of an exclusive club
that
i found that i shunned it on purpose it
was part of like who i was
it's like oh i don't need i'm not the
olympian i'm something else
but it's kind of i got fun to embrace it
um and
i got involved in more and more and more
things um
i started doing some uh uh do
do being asked to do events with uh
la-24 which is now la-28
back then it was la 2024 of the la bid
for the for the uh for the olympic
paralympic games
and i just started having more and more
and more fun and and
and as with most paths that you
initially resist
taking oftentimes you start realizing
well maybe
maybe there's a reason that i started
down this juncture
and um the then president
of the southern california olympians and
paralympians
was moving and she asked me if i would
like to assume the presidency
and again i was reluctant but i did it
um and
it's just been kind of a snowball effect
and
i've gotten incredible joy out of
working with with children like i'm
i i work a lot with ready set gold
which is um it's an organization that
sends olympians and paralympians
into schools all over southern
california to teach
the importance of health and fitness too
elementary school and junior high
kids not not so unlike the message that
you
i'm sure sit you know talk about all the
time throughout your career
um and and then you know various
foundations that raise money
um the trident swim foundation who
we are raising money for uh uh swim
programs and underserved neighborhoods
where they don't have access to pools
and they don't have access to
college counseling and so it's a hybrid
of swim team
college counseling to really show
kids that aren't necessarily exposed
like we were to
what the world is outside of high school
and af you know and as far as
undergraduate yeah and so it's just
exposing them to that and i've just been
i've just been really really enjoying it
um
all the while kind of keeping one foot
in you know in the entertainment
business i
uh created a a series um
a game show actually was that the one
with the like the stock cars
yeah yeah it's where you showed me the
trailer yeah you where you strap
you strap contestants into the passenger
seat or race car drive being driven by a
race car driver and they have to
uh they have to um answer trivia
questions like in on jeopardy
like pulling g's yeah yeah just having
having the absolute daylight scared out
of them
it was like that clip in um what was the
movie the ford versus ferrari
yeah right like like where they put the
deuce
ford the second right right right yes
indeed it was like that except
we were trying to stump them that seems
like a no-brainer
it is a no-brainer uh as far as concept
goes uh
but when you learn something in
production along the way and sometimes
things are just
they're just there's too many working
parts there's too many volatile
links in the chain that if one breaks
the whole thing falls apart yeah
and we just had one too many of those
things happen so
for that reason primarily it just didn't
take off there was a lot of people super
excited about that and
and i actually joined forces with
bertrand van munster
to do that and we always had a we always
shared
our gear head you know we we love
cars right yeah you're a car guy yeah
yeah do you have you have a shelby right
i used to i
sold i sold it yeah i sold it yeah i
sold it to my college roommate
he did yeah yeah he sends me
pictures every once in a while when he
takes her out uh-huh so you must have
loved ford versus ferrari i did
well i know this the book is fantastic
it's called go like hell
and the book is like very much
unfiltered the movie of course is much
more filtered and not
as authentic but the story they stuck to
the story that story is
absolutely what happened um but yeah
yeah well i totally enjoyed it i mean
the book is just
anybody that wants to is a gearhead and
likes that era of
racing read the book go like hell right
um
back to the paralympic thing yeah you
know that's a world that i don't know
that much about like yeah like help me
to understand like
what is it that we don't understand
about these extraordinary athletes
that you have a glimpse into well you
you were in a you you were in
a unique position where if you chose to
you could work with these athletes and i
know
that you've worked with people with
impairments in fact one of uh
i'm i'm sorry i'm blanking on his name
uh who was uh who did the five for five
the
episode yeah who um you know he's he's
got a he's got a
uh on arm right yeah he he doesn't have
the functional use of his
right arm although he doesn't like to
identify like he he
he would prefer to just you know do his
own thing but he did win the sb
for being uh like the the i i can't
the carry like best you know disabled
athlete of the year or something like
that
yeah i guess i i i sort of like went off
off track of what your question is but
you work with the uh these aspiring
para athletes who have uh have to use
very
varying degrees of adaption in order to
um
in order to function athletically and
you realize that every single one of
them
is is is a puzzle and it's a puzzle for
them too because their body doesn't work
right
and you know there's so many different
ways and you and i we know the basics
the foundations of swimming
but when you work for example with uh
with
a paralympic swimmer or an aspiring
paralympic swimmer there's a
there's there's like a there's like a
code that you need to crack and it's
they need you need to help them crack it
as well because that code's different
for every aspect every aspect they all
have a different situation
and and here's the thing i've worked
with a lot of very good swimmers through
the years i just i haven't really
been i haven't really aspired to coach
but i've also seen that oftentimes
swimmers specifically and i'm sure it's
like this with most athletes
who have achieved a certain amount of
success they have very
a very lazy fair attitude toward getting
told something new
in fact there's some resistance excuse
me
but these para athletes they're just i
mean put put yourself in their shoes
like many of them they they were
completely functional before an accident
some of them were born that way but just
think of the
the level of frustration and aspiration
and bravery that it takes in order to
say i want to be an
athlete i want to do this even though my
arm doesn't work right or my legs are
paralyzed
it's it's these people are like
enthusiasm
turned up to 11. um and they're just a
they're
they're collectively just an incredibly
passionate group and that's what
originally sunk the hooks in me i worked
with a
organization called angel city sports
um and the first time i worked with him
was i believe it was 2017
and uh it was formed specifically
to provide a paralympic style
competition and development platform
for athletes from all over the world but
specifically united states to compete
in one place and it's held over the
course of a certain amount of days at
ucla
oh cool like a national sports festival
kind of thing exactly
and it's called angel city games and so
i've been i've been part of that
and as president of southern california
olympians and paralympians we we take
part
in not only doing clinics and helping
various athletes but also like in the
opening ceremonies and
and this year was only different and
that everything was
by remote like how how the heck do you
do a remote swimming clinic but we
pulled it off
and i i i enlisted the
the expertise of a very good friend of
mine who was on the 1980 olympic team
with me a guy named glenn mills
who specializes in stroke technique and
has probably the greatest repository of
swimming technique videos yeah it's
unbelievable and they're all available
online and he
he and he swim tv or something it's go
swim
tv go swim tv yeah yeah and he he and
and so he i thankfully i i you know i
thought to bring him in because he he
just made it
he made it magic and you know there's
just a there's just a lot of magic
that are is involved with the paralympic
movement that is very very different
while being the same as the olympic
movement
there's a purity to it too right yeah it
feels
uncorrupted by you know the
the you know the corporate forces that
you know grind us all down like there's
just something
more innocent about it and real yeah i
think
i mean maybe that i don't know why that
is uh maybe it's just their pers
their collective perspective is so much
different than an able-bodied athlete
but i think it's also you know you talk
about the corruption of
of of all things commercial you know
at some point those athletes are going
to really start getting
some commercial exposure and it's
curious you know whether or not
things will things will change you know
the
the atmosphere and sort of like the
movement will
will change when these athletes become
celebrated for what they are which is
amazing athletes with incredible hearts
which is what the whole olympic movement
is all about
yeah yeah inevitable i suppose what do
you think is going to happen with tokyo
i don't know i have no idea you you ask
anybody high up in the olymp you know in
the olympic and paralympic
world and that's the answer i get nobody
nobody nobody really knows nobody at
some point
a decision is going to have to be made
though because there's so
many moving pieces here well there's so
much writing on it
there's so much writing on it i mean if
they don't do it this summer what does
that mean for the olympic movement at
large
i don't know i don't know it makes me it
makes me shudder to think
the damage yeah i mean we're in a we're
in a time covet has created a
a world where we're looking at so much
of what we've
known and taken for granted is
is being is being pulled apart and
deflated piece by piece um
and i'm i'm terrified that if somehow
the 2021 games
don't happen that tokyo will be fine
tokyo is a big you know city with you
know lots and lots of money
they will make a rebound but the olympic
movement man you know it won't
it would it won't be since like 1980
that the u.s olympic movement was almost
ruined by the 1980 boycott
and i just hope it doesn't get to that
point i just pray that that these
these athletes can go and compete and
that the olympic movement can do what
they set out to do which is
send athletes to go compete at the
olympic and paralympic games
and pursue their dreams yeah that's a
good place to
land this plane but before i let you go
words of wisdom from the life experience
of an olympian when you talk to
young people or young athletes like what
is it that you
want to impart to that person about
personal
um potential and the path towards
connecting with you know the best
version
of who you can be yeah um
i was just a normal kid growing up i
never had olympic aspirations nor did i
ever dream that i could achieve such
heights
i would have never like if if if my
teachers
and my fellow students were to look at
me
you know in fifth or sixth grade and
say okay one of you is going to go to
the olympic compete in the olympic games
and eventually go study at stanford
it wouldn't wouldn't have been me and it
was not on my radar either
and my point is is that my life
was transformed not by going to
the olympic games but by
the desire and aspirations to go to the
olympic games and the hard work
and dedication that it took to get to
that point where i could even fathom
going to the olympic games
and in that respect that aspect of life
is accessible to anyone and
you don't have to be you don't have to
aspire to be
an olympic athlete or a paralympic
athlete maybe you aspire to be
a like a a a political activist a local
political activist
or a a professor in sociology
or an actor
or or a guru of podcasts
such as yourself no no but i mean my
point
is that that you can you can do it with
applying yourself and matt that's where
the magic happens
is realizing that if you dedicate
yourself yourself towards something that
you can begin writing your own tickets
beautifully put my friend thank you i
love you john moffatt
thank you very much today i'm so
happy that we are able to hang out and
share stories and
and uh commune uh because it is few and
far between
unfortunately just because of of
of our of our lives being busy yeah
super so grateful
uh to have you in my life and to have
this experience with you today man
i love you so much and that was um
very meaningful to me uh and i think
people are going to get a lot out of it
so
thanks thanks for it means it means a
lot for you to
want me to be on your podcast because it
only it took seven years from the last
time i got it done
uh although i look at the folks that you
are have
been able to interview with through the
years and it's just an
unbelievable array the the distance that
you have have come
from those you know from 1990 or night
uh 2007 when you were first starting
embarking upon your journey which i
remember very clearly to
to now it's a testament to what i was
talking about that
you know hard work and dedication and a
vision and realizing that
that you might be able to write your
ticket if you work hard and do it it's
never guaranteed
yeah well i appreciate that man thank
you uh yeah like i said i used to visit
you at the paramount lot
and i was like is there any job here
could you you're like
well you could become in a city like i
was like trying to figure out what i
wanted to do and it you know it took a
very long time but
um grateful to be where i am man
cool uh so if you're digging on john the
new podcast
might be called uh sports life balance
balance coming towards a podcast
platform do you have a release date
for it i'm we're looking toward
releasing it during the holidays at some
point
around thanksgiving okay into the
holidays cool
um i'll be sure to share that out and uh
any any anywhere else you want to point
people
well look look uh look for rich roll as
one of my guests that's right we're
gonna we're gonna now we're gonna take a
break and then we're gonna
just keep rolling right into your
podcast so um yeah honored to be a guest
on your show and when
of course that goes up i'll i'll let all
you guys know so thanks man
i really appreciate it peace
[Music]
you